[Music]
anyway
uh update
can i be clear before we start this
video
i already know that flooring i already
know that staircase we all know anybody
watching this knows
any any old-time rotc fan knows so
what's funny is this weekend i was i put
a bunch of clips up because we were like
backlogged on clips because we had that
strike so we couldn't upload for like a
week to the clip channel but of course
taper cup clippings so i just uploaded a
whole bunch of them but i was getting
some comments and a lot of the comments
were like i don't want to be the one to
say it but we need more date and
hypernova we need more date and hyper
number here's what happened
we had another clip up on the clip
channel date hyper but that video was
taken down
i'm not even going to say
the words of why i was taken down
because they're looking for any reason
but let's say it was just taken down for
something we spoke of earlier
on twitter that happened to alex pearson
let's put it that way right so whatever
of course if you remember that video we
never mentioned anything about that
thing
all we did was goof on him
maybe mention it in passing but nothing
else however
that was what they used to take it down
so i want to be clear here
this video we're about to watch
is somebody we've covered for a very
long time we're not talking about
anything that has to do with benny
politics any medical stuff this is just
somebody that we like to cover who is
somebody who has their [ __ ] out there on
youtube and has for years anyway
title of this video can i also just say
real quick safe and effective just just
to cover our base brought to you by
pfizer um
title of this video from dayton
hypernova is mom and dad complaining how
a person who hasn't honored their word
to them isn't considerate hypocrites
nice title now you know it's funny you
can read this in any way and it still
makes the same makes the same amount of
sense watch hypocrites have considered
is them to word their honored hazard who
person a how complaining that mom
yeah that's
that's a dayton title so
he uses every character like he uses
every character they allow you to use in
a title so here we go
now as you know with dayton video i
haven't watched any of this by the way
it's not even when i skim this one i
just got like very recently so
we can't really hear what they're saying
downstairs but now here we go he goes to
his room now before we
i want you to look at the floor
i want everybody to look at the floor
let me make this full screen
the dust and stuff because there's new
people that might not know god that's
from his that's from his that's his skin
from because
he has
eczema really bad so he's we've
literally seen him making videos of him
sweeping up his skin so what you see on
the floor isn't like dirt by the way
he's also messy look at the garbage on
the floor the thing is i'm messy too
right but like a simple
you know picking up some stuff when it
starts to get messy and honestly the
lifesaver man this guy just needs a dust
buster like
that's that's changed the game for me
just get a dust buster homie he's he's
he's molting somebody said
[Music]
and you know what i'm noticing always
like foundation you know what i'm
noticing did you notice something the
rest of the house is really clean you
could see that right yeah it's just his
little picture just little his little
thing now for those pig style yeah
look
i've explained there's an entire
playlist on the clip's channel if you
want to know who dayton is more
specifically
that's his elderly mother walking
downstairs who pays oh my god bro we've
never really gotten this much this look
at his room no
honestly he never he rarely go he really
usually goes to the bathroom bro look at
this he's a hoarder
yeah that is
see i can't let things get too messy
before i start to go crazy
what a f
[ __ ] pig man don't do that
oh no no
no you didn't even notice that when you
first got no no no no no
oh yeah oh yeah that's those are those
sheets never get washed
no
this is disgusting this is so even like
it looks like an old it looks like a
[ __ ] like an old person died in that
bed what the [ __ ] is it i i
[Applause]
i am i am
[ __ ] horrified
brought to you by pfizer
thank you
they have a cat
that cat's waiting for him to die
i just overheard my parents talking well
that cat and me have a lot in common um
i won't i don't i'm sure i'm just cuz
voice is getting a little deeper is
somebody missing some treatments
no here's the thing with him just so you
guys know this is this is not me we're
not criticizing anything we're just
saying
he
doesn't take
any um any treatment
like
he just just dresses differently like
he's not taking any treatment or
anything like hrt or anything
um
and also look at the bulge
now why everybody look at the bulge i
did no everybody look at the balls all
right we looked i refused okay
in their bedroom and they were talking
for like quite a while i just turned the
camera on but they were talking
i don't know it seemed like a half hour
or something but anyway they were
talking for quite a while my mom was
very upset talking about uh space
monster in the rumble track goes he
plays like six cats dead under the bed
one
who
needed to
someone who had agreed to do something
to help them with their palms i mean
they have a pond in the backyard
something to do with their pond and
gardens and the situation whatever it is
um
i couldn't really comprehend everything
that they were saying
oh
slurring again he's uh yeah you are
pilled up yeah yeah kind of
parts of conversation i couldn't really
hear but anyway every every time i heard
my mom like really talk angry
uh it was about
some it seemed to be about
the
them reaching out or whatever to ever
texting a person who wasn't texting back
and and she was like
talking to my dad about how
they as in her and him like she was
basically saying that
how um my dad oh my god can we get to it
he's getting there be that inconsiderate
to a person who's being that
inconsiderate and i mean my parents are
the biggest [ __ ] hypocrites
then move
yeah
get rid of those [ __ ] you're not paying
rent why don't you move
imaginable in
the situation of my life
they're like huge hypocrites so it's
ironic for her to even like i wish i
would have recorded when i heard her say
that
now here talking on the phone downstairs
anyway i think
yeah it sounds like someone's on the
phone
anyway um
dude his voice there's something going
on i don't know if it's medication
adjustment or what it is
all right maybe i should go for it
you know psoriasis here we go here we go
this [ __ ] over here
you know arms and legs
um just
all right you don't have to show it look
at his foot everyone look at his foot
everyone look at his head that is
disgusting
i'm trying to look away and then i look
at the floor and then i look back at the
foot there's nowhere to look there's
nowhere to look frozen everybody
look at the foot it's like he opened up
the ark of the covenant here hold on i'm
uh clipping it there it is
it looks like a [ __ ] chemical pronoun
oh my god oh my god put it back up uh
there it is um oh my god dude
dude
that is
bad
his leg looks like a prop from the set
of the reanimator
it's bad right
it's disgusting [ __ ] that bleeds i mean
i've started taking treats
disgusting [ __ ] that bleeds but enough
about women am i right
um hey really has to have a bunch of
unhappy healthy habits that are
in you know a real quick check
exacerbating that eczema check show
links real quick i tossed something in
there oh come on man
why would you do that
today's gonna be my day to get revenge
dayton hyperfoot
recently but i never really knew
anything about turmeric before and i
didn't know it helped that much while it
helps the room is just covered with like
amazon packages and ebay and you saw the
ebay stuff too because he uses there's
his parents credit card to order dresses
for his boutique that time when i was
getting beat regularly i never didn't do
anything about it he was getting beat by
his dead brother turmeric i thought it
would help me a lot and i couldn't
afford any reason for those few new
viewers on rumble you want to maybe
explain his business model okay so the
business model of this boutique is
dayton hypernova what she
wants to do is is that she
wants to get um order order like
hand-me-down stuff like you know
second-hand stuff from a goodwill or
from ebay or whatever right
and then what he's what she is gonna do
is she is going to open a boutique store
where people can go in but if you think
how if you think oh well that's not a
bad idea i mean if you mark up the
prices enough you don't have to pay see
because in dayton hypernova's boutique
store
you could it's free if you want but they
just ask for a donation but he believes
in the kindness of people so people are
just going to donate enough money to
keep it open and to pay rent to pay for
power and pay for water and time why are
the people that are always talking about
the kindness of people are always the
ones that need the kindness are always
also not kind themselves too that's what
i mean and they're never giving kindness
yeah
treatments yeah we need to fix this
we'll take a penny leave up anything
here with these people
right it's yeah you always take 20
pennies and you're taking all the
pennies yeah you know at a dermatologist
office you know
at my income level which what's your
income level nothing income level you
make a hundred dollars
you don't even have to file
which was based on my parents idea of
what i
deserved
first off it's [ __ ] up your parents
because they still can't claim you as a
dependent because they should be able to
right
from what i work like for working plus
i'll be honest with you i don't think
that's what they think you deserve
i think if you ask them they're paying
you more than they think you deserve
the house made they're paying for you to
shut up and you never shut up
uh you know laundry and house here it is
here it is
cleaning up
35 years old new rumble people 35 years
old
uh trans lives living with his parents
for as long as we've been covering her
her sorry if i miss gender i mean they
i'm going to just say dayton
dayton
um
has
used to live with his mo his brother
used to live their sherman and he said
his brother used to beat him up because
he was trans that never happened by the
way no the police the the police
department knows him because he's a
problem uh the lgbtq community in
dayton hate him they've said it that's
not us saying it that's them
he's insufferable he steals his mom's
credit card to buy stuff for that little
boutique store that i told you earlier
uh one time his dad was being nice
because dayton by the way both of his
parents were like in their mid 70s
dayton was asking that he wanted pizza
his dad ordered pizza but he didn't
order it
from the right pizza place the one that
dayton likes
so he got mad and started screaming at
his father he made his dad wake up at
four in the morning and drive three
hours so he could meet nicole richie at
a at a comic book convention
god that's right
oh and he threw uh on christmas i
believe he threw a wine glass at his
brother's head oh yeah and said he was
abusive oh yeah he broke he broke a wine
glass on his brother's head to the
people who abused me
all this [ __ ] and they were politely
they were asked to politely leave an
outback steakhouse because they were
fighting so i remember the outbacks
christina ricci by the way not nicole i
apologize you're right i apologize
i apologize one of those hoes a long
long long rant more than
necessary
owen benjamin's ex
the whole point is these people are
crazy [ __ ]
yeah they're nuts you could see how nuts
they are i could see it you're letting a
skinhead beat me
dayton moment was when he he was just
like filming you know yeah as he as he
does he's filming his family
and her his his sisters uh his
brother-in-law just looks over at him
goes
hi dayton
yes
and then he hit it then he would have
hit that guy he talked [ __ ] about him
then he went in the closet
oh that reminds us
also he calls his
brother-in-law a
a nazi when his brother-in-law is black
oh that's right actually
his brother-in-law's a nazi and his
brothers he calls his brother a nazi
even though his brother's long since
been dead and he's mad at his sister
because she only has two pride flags
it's not enough and she needs more oh my
god everything he does is oh by the way
understand there's and we're forgetting
things you do people honestly tell you
watch that playlist
you
this guy's story this woman's story
this woman's story
is
i know i know this woman's story
is so
pathetic
and hilarious
and we so far are the only ones that got
the juice for these because these are
unlisted and you only post in one place
and daddy's got an inside source since
uh spring 20 also he's a professional
tinfoil artist oh my god i forgot about
the tinfoil art that was art
so he
he used a bunch of his parents aluminum
foil
after his brother died while they were
grieving okay keep this in mind the
timing is important
his parents are grieving he made them
try
he's making tinfoil art in the city
drive him to the store to buy a bunch of
rolls of ted
so he could make tin foil art
they didn't pay me uh
seven months of uh
i think it was about seven months or six
or seven months of uh 20 at the year
2020 the during the pandemic lockdowns i
worked every week of that year and they
only basically paid me 50 of that year
like bare like probably slightly they
only paid him 50 i want to keep in mind
for people that don't know
his parents don't have to pay them they
give him a hundred dollars because they
feel bad yeah the only thing that they
ask him to do we've seen this several
times is okay but you have to do the all
of our laundry and we'll give you a
hundred dollars a week
he doesn't even do the laundry no he
doesn't even do that no and they still
pay him
less because i think it was like nearly
seven months or something like that and
like
basically they skipped payments for two
entire seasons of the year
and uh
but that's good for you see when you're
filing taxes if they paid you under the
table and
that means you
you keep more of your money is he stupid
yes
you idiot that's what you want that way
if you're making that less money also i
bet oh my god merch [ __ ] i i just
figured out what the issue is here
their parents are just
they're doing half of it under the table
because they want them to still qualify
for all the medical programs because
he's under the poverty level of course
so they're probably doing it as a favor
i has to because i let's just say that i
know situations where that occurs right
he probably gets he gets ssi or
something of course and there's a
threshold of how much money you make
versus how much you get right
they're probably doing it as a favor so
he doesn't get [ __ ]
and he's out there going like and they
didn't give me until i say that much
money they gave me so when i found taxes
i wish his parents would give him fifty
thousand dollar one time that way he
loses all his benefits for a year
that's okay that's all fifty thousand
dollars but they have to report it as
payment
and they skipped all of last summer
which wasn't another thousand dollars
they didn't pay
um so all in all that was full by the
way
they didn't get a chance to pay it
because they were um
not this summer but last summer they
were um
grieving the death of their other son
yeah their other son the good one well
the better one
wrong queer dad um
[ __ ]
that's probably why they might have been
a little behind in the summer dayton
four thousand dollars between three
thousand dollars and twenty twenty and
one thousand dollars last year and this
year they skipped like two months or so
they're living he's living in their
house for free
they're buying all his food they're
giving him a hundred dollars and he's
complaining
of course he's still doing this merch
when we started this this was like four
years ago
when it started it's been a journey
this is an og right
um
this is like when i had a chalkboard
behind me
kind of [ __ ] um and
he's only getting worse
since his brother it's yeah because he's
he doesn't he's lose he now doesn't even
have like his main
villain anymore to play most problems on
this guy
you're right i remember we said it
remember we said it as soon as his
brother died we called this we go he
doesn't have a villain anymore so he's
gonna get worse he's gonna get worse
because he's gonna now remember he's
gonna deteriorate he doesn't have at
least something to focus on yep god
frozen
also he had device errors so the in the
beginning he he had the laptop the
laptop he filmed exclusively on a laptop
then he went to his phone and then again
are you are you oh you use a used ipad
yep and now back to his phone i guess i
guess you can wait on the ipad the phone
is his brother's old phone it's like oh
another 500 or something so it was like
over four thousand almost five point
almost five thousand dollars i haven't
been paid since spring of 2020 for the
work that i do which is remember when
his dad said oh my god man i remember
this is like sparking so much stuff
remember when his dad said
if i give you what was the amount like
ten thousand dollars right now will you
move out remember that yeah and he's
like and he goes no i won't take it he's
like okay so i'll give you ten thousand
dollars right now but you have to move
out and that only not only did he have
to move right away he was still going to
give him 90 days he goes i'll give you
10 000
and then in 90 days you have to move out
he said no
below minimum wage and it's you know
non-tip hey roger forgetting one
point in the story and danny
just said it remember the producer of
the dr phil show yeah so then the
producer of the dr phil show contacted
him do you remember that
did was that a real thing yeah yeah the
producer of dr phil i never knew if that
was a troll or not yeah it was me by the
way
enough times i was gonna say i thought
it was a troll enough time has gone by
look it was me okay
i i was the producer for the doctors
weren't you where wasn't the whole bit
like would you like to meet christina
ricci yes
and i pers i forgot i think i used
emmanuel rodriguez actually and i
presented myself as a producer for dr
phil
and um
i remember my first message was like hi
earl schultz this is this earl schultz i
was given information because i re i
heard that you wanted to be on dr phil
because he kept saying want to be on dr
phil
and he replied he goes yes but earl
don't please don't deadname me my name
is like he actually corrected the print
like he almost like imagine if i really
was a producer right
you're about to blow it all because they
called you earl but then he corrected me
and i apologize you go earl i'm so sorry
for dead naming you buh-buh-bye i really
apologize
um
and then he kind of got hip to it i
don't know how i think he just kind of
got scared
but he really was like and and cr and
and uh he was and my brother beats me in
this house and i really want to go on
there and show you my narcissistic
parents and then he would say he sent me
like all the videos that he had done
but then he figured it out and he
stopped talking to me
yeah yeah you know what are you gonna do
yeah
earl sorry earl
the wages so it's below minimum wage for
how low it is it's ridiculous and these
people are uh you know
it was me dayton it was me all
right
the brother's still alive he comes out
no nah the brother shows up in the
mirror like the ultimate warrior yes
and then for some reason hulk can see
him and for some reason we can all see
him but for some reason bishop can't see
him yeah which is what he's well planned
for money
and
they are breaking the law
okay but i'll tell you what thing if
they're breaking the law you know what
you should do
report them
report them report them
not
paying the regular employee
regularly you're not an employee
they're giving you an allowance and
they're relying on the tax returns which
i didn't even turn in this year because
i refused to sign something that was a
lie
they tried to pass as a lie
are are you about are you publicly
trying
to imply that your parents committed tax
fraud to help you
you understand if they get in trouble
and they put a lien on that house you're
not gonna have a place to live what are
you doing this is not very long-term
thinking or is it very gracious and i'll
even be honest with you i
look this is not normally i try to skim
through the dayton videos because i
prefer to be shocked by everybody else
but i didn't even look at this one i got
this one like late and i just threw in
the prep bag so i kind of feel bad
because i didn't know i don't want to
his parents are really nice right
and i don't want to get them in trouble
you know
because this guy's an idiot what is
wrong with you man those are your
parents dude and they just lost their
other kid and they're still taking care
of you and you're trying to get him in
trouble for tax fraud because he's a
miserable selfish [ __ ] because there's
no consideration for the people that
feed him and and house him and the means
justify the ends always well the ends
justify the means always with this
person wow what a [ __ ] dick
he does know that the house
once that happens the house doesn't go
to him it goes to the bank it goes to
the bank i don't know what he's doing
you know it's pitiful and i have a copy
of that which we didn't sign i have a
copy of
that
are you tr is he tr implying that he's
going to blackmail them yeah this is now
extortion feels like that's a paper that
as um
that i was supposed to sign that i
didn't sign when i saw the you know they
tried to sneak past me they were saying
that i didn't work as much as i did i
worked every week of last year so they
tried to lie about how much i worked
just to cover their asses and now you're
gonna have these inept irs cops going in
there we saw how bad they are just
shooting everybody
when they are shooting each other in the
back everyone's dead the liars they're
fundamentalist christians
who are wealthy and by the way
i want to be clear here they are not
wealthy no they they're not broke but
they live in dayton ohio yeah and the
father worked really hard and bought a
home you know what i mean but he still
he relies on social security
every book in the bible that talks about
how horrible
man you guys you know you people who
hate the bible sure do love quoting it
whenever can you know it's convenient
for you
hey i don't have any respect for your
religion or your traditions but i'm
going to throw them in your face to make
you do what i want
religious people are well you know i
like getting camels of that eye of the
needle types you know that you
completely butchered that five bible
verse by the way taking a camel to an
eye of a needle that's not
level of sin and wealthy people who
can't get to heaven all that stuff in
because i wear women's clothing i'm a
sinner
going to hell because one or two
scriptures let me explain something to
you
whether you believe in the concept of
heaven or not that's everyone's
individual choice but let's say we sent
you using christianity let's just do
this do you think that the reason you
wouldn't get into heaven is because you
wear women's clothing or do you think
the reason you wouldn't get into heaven
is because you have no respect for your
father for your mother for your brother
and now you're trying to get them in
trouble with the law you constantly
steal their stuff you have zero respect
for anybody around you you hate your
sister um
i mean
the entire lgbtq community hates you do
you think that the reason is because
you're wearing culottes
is that the reason you think it is
because i don't really think so i don't
think that's the problem i have a
feeling that i don't think so in
biblical times all these dudes wore
these dresses i don't think that's the
problem here i don't think that's a
problem yeah
i think the problem is you yeah by the
way scottish people that wear kilts
don't go to heaven either apparently
like what is that none of them what an
idiot this guy [ __ ] is
telling me roddy piper's not going to
heaven yeah come on
about that which i please are old
testament
which has nothing to do with jesus
teachings and everything about their
behavior goes against jesus teaching i
mean all of that stuff about letting the
skinhead beat the [ __ ] out of me that
was actually in i think leviticus
paying me a very low wage that is
criminally low
and then skipping i think that was in
second john
thousands of dollars um all this
ridiculous [ __ ] well you know i'm just
getting some record right now about the
fact that they're like that just before
i
uh started recording or like i get for a
while before i start recording or
decided to
record this video while they were still
bickering about whatever talking about
they're talking about some hypocritical
pers
and
they're picking about whatever they were
talking about getting a moving van for
that [ __ ] that lives upstairs i'm not
really sure who they're talking about
they were talking about like doing an
eviction notice for somebody that lived
in the house that was upstairs yes
somebody that kept making all of us
upset that we all hate yeah but i mean i
don't know who they're talking about
because sherman's not here it's probably
my sister maybe she's going to move back
in and there's probably
can't be sherman because he's dead i
don't mean to worry about though by the
way sherman died of aluminum poisoning
i'm just putting that out there
is it that's that's i'm kidding
oh my god because of the stupid artwork
it took me a second i'm like wait what
yeah
that was the whole plan shovel on twist
it was me austin it was me all along
exactly this house
well he does look he does look like he
does look like a pill man
person agreed to do for like their
pawned
yeah it's white people problems [ __ ]
it's not basically they in their own
they're complaining and really calling
their black friend to uh you know their
only black friend who's a pro the only
pro trump black by the way he has no
friends white black or any kind yeah but
he's calling them out
that is in the city of dayton basically
this is her like good friend
and you know they're just like
wow so they're friends with a black guy
who who holds the same values and
traditions they do
what then i guess that means they're not
racist you dumb [ __ ]
no for real i know you're other person
no you're oh yeah
one black guy friend that they only like
because they agree with him on many of
life's issues yeah that's what a friend
is
now if they were racist they would be
like wow i'm not even gonna be friends
with this guy even though he's cool and
based
because i can't i can't be consorting
with them in my home
going to him to
it sounds like they're going to him to
you know get
him to do the work that somebody else
promised to do so i'm just like i'm
venting a little bit obviously about
this but it's just fascinating to me
because it just feels like poetic
justice and it's ridiculous like the
kind of hypocrisy that goes on in this
family all the violence and cheating and
people out of money and then you know
complaining and then literally having
the audacity to say it's like we would
never be this inconsiderate to a person
like you spent seven years allowing a
skin hit to beat the [ __ ] out of it bro
he hasn't stopped the line
no and it's like he's been dead now for
a while homie yeah
person half the size of skinhead like
who was wearing dresses around the
skinhead it's like just my mom's like
right out there uh
walking around so i'm like if i can
man i'm looking at their yard and their
lawn really it's true it's it's
perfectly manicured it's only his room
it's a mess that she walked
over there
anyway i
just fent it's ridiculous
i don't know but it's just who are you
venting to dayton i'm like the only
person we're the only people that watch
this video now
that's a lot of lip burp bees [ __ ]
lip wax i'm just recording this as a
video diary about how insanely
ridiculously hypocritical
and bigoted my family are they're
religious bigots and they are thieves
and they are hypocrites
and
they're
long rules
they're what
mongrels girls did he call them mongrels
but then you're but you're living off of
them right what does that make you
a flea yeah parasite that feeds off of
mongrels
horrible people i'm just venting at them
mongrel technically isn't racist
but mongrel is definitely something you
would add to a racist word as a as a of
course it's like a good racist adjective
to add in there no but it's like okay
then dayton
here's the thing right if i thought that
people were like
seriously like genocidal maniacs like
complete psychos like or like satanic
accelerationists
oh that's the name of my band
i'd be like
yeah i'm not going to be associated with
you people i'm not going to live here
i'm not going to be a part of this
so if there's such horrible people why
are you lifting off of them it feels a
bit
weird like how would you do that with a
good well because because he has eczema
and he has anxiety and because of those
things remember remember at the very
beginning of this
he had he had just come back from moving
very beginning of the saga he had come
back because he was living with friends
and apparently
something happened that all his friends
put his [ __ ] in the yard and told him to
leave the house he was staying his
roommates don't leave the house he was
at like again he was the problem there
too
of course there's a theme because it's
absolutely disgraceful
it's sad
yeah i'm gonna move the [ __ ] out of here
i guess because okay lean ridiculous and
the is weather's to be bad enough soon
again it's going to start affecting my
psoriasis all over my body right now
it's as mild as
it's just i mean
because it's the middle of summer so i
should probably get the hell out of here
you know say whatever the heck open
leave exactly
you've been saying this for five years
now you know what else has opened the
second story window
yeah go for it go chris chan right out
that window
your first statements are decent enough
even though the only thousands more i
would be doing a lot better if they
actually honored what they are supposed
to do
in their lives
dane i'll give you ten thousand dollars
right now you move out
i'll give it to you for my own money if
you leave
i'll throw in a couple bucks
so ten thousand and five dollars right
now
[Laughter]
merch has some upcoming expenditures
that he has to worry about that's he has
to worry about